this is a production of cornell
university
okay well thank you sorry we couldn't
meet in person we've been talking about
this presentation
uh for some time and and had to make it
virtual
but uh we'll do the best we can so i am
the statewide uh veteran pathologist for
uh
for indiana
and uh uh as such i get a lot of
questions about fungicides the the
question that that i want to talk about
today is the interaction between rain
and fungicides
and the photo here is uh tomato plants
in the foreground but we have a storm
cloud coming uh so i want to talk about
the interaction of perhaps fungicides
placed on these
on these uh tomato plants with the storm
coming but really i have to kind of back
up and also talk today a little bit
about
uh the interaction between diseased
and and rain
plant disease and rain
so
in going around indiana uh these are
three of the most common questions that
that i get
uh the first question and we'll try to
answer these questions today should i
wait until it rains before i apply a
fungicide in other words a rain is
predicted
for this afternoon or tomorrow should i
wait until
after that rain before i apply a
fungicide or should i apply it before
the second related question then is if i
apply a fungicide before rain how long
before the rain is safe an hour two
hours 12 hours
third third question is i applied a
fungicide yesterday and it rained today
should i reapply that fungicide
so first let's go back and and why do we
apply fungicides and of course we apply
fungicides to help with the disease but
it's important to remember
we apply fungicides to help prevent
foliar disease we don't
uh
it really doesn't do it much good or any
good to to apply foot decides to already
disease plants so we want to apply
fungicides on a regular basis to prevent
foliar disease
most foliar diseases and this is the
critical point here
most foliar diseases require water
on the leaf surface
because they they have to have water to
allow those spores to infect the leaf
so i show a photo i found for agnes of
watermelon here but i could show many
many many different
foliar diseases of vegetables
that where water is required for for
that infection to occur
rain is is then necessary to disperse
those spores so if you imagine a
raindrop hitting these uh
uh lesions here
um
and it would splash the spores to other
leaves so rain is is just the critical
component of spreading most foliar
diseases of vegetables
so if you uh
decide to zone out here that the most
important point is is if at all possible
have your fungicides applied before the
rain
not after before the rain because rain
is where you most need this fungicide to
protect the leaf
so i'd like to clear up a term before i
before i go on and that term is rain
fastness or rain fast
uh there's different complicated
definitions but it essentially comes
down to the effectiveness of a foliar
fungicide application after a rain event
how how well does your fungicide work
after the rain has occurred
and you see here a watermelon leaf with
the with a fungicide on on the leaf
i'll be talking about a labels and
fungicides and so rainfast or
rainfastness is one thing you'd want to
search your fungicide label for this
this term
so when i was first asked to give this
talk
uh several years ago
i thought well this this will be easy i
will um
i'll just search the labels
for rain fast or rain fastness and and
and then go through each label and then
i'll come up with for each label
when is it rain fast or is it rain fast
what conditions under which it is it
rain fast
so i i i didn't search every single
label i suppose but i i searched the
vast majority of labels that you would
use in vegetable production
and the their search results were
disappointing
a few of the products and we'll see
these in a moment few of these products
had information on rainfastness on the
label
this was true regardless of the name
uh for example uh a manchester product
guy thing rain shield you think that
would say something about rain fastness
but it did not
bravo weather stick a chlorothalonil
product uh does al also just says
nothing on the label about
whether or how long before it's rain
fast
this is what i found so i'd like to go
over this there's not many
uh products and i'd like to go over
these because uh
they'll give you a sense of what to look
for so the first uh product is approach
and if you look on the label it says
it's rain fast after an hour well that
tells you
exactly what you want to know if you
apply approach an hour before a rain
uh it it is that they're standing behind
that product being rain fast there's a
couple of copper products champ and
co-side
which say eight hours but only for
ginseng so that must have been special
uh special research
um
uh kurzate uh two hours
and doris and and pristine both say yes
well what does that mean well
essentially i guess it means that the
manufacturer is standing behind that
indora and pristine are rain fast but
they're not telling you how long
what period of time to wait
fontellus and vertisan both say an hour
monsoon onset toledo and i think vibe is
in that group two to four hours
presidio's two hours we mentioned
pristine
propamax quilt excel quilt and tilt all
say dry so
what this apparently means is when the
product is drying the leaf which does
not take long
the manufacturer is saying these
products are rain fast rhyme is two
hours and tunnels uh one hour
i searched some
selected uh organic labels and again did
not find much milstop and cernet opti
had had verbage such that you have to
apply them more often during rainy
weather
and then oxidate heads had a comment
about uh a rainy weather and severe
conditions which i don't understand
because oxidate doesn't have any residue
i don't see how it interacts with rain
at all but that's another story
so i didn't find much
um what factors affect rain fast and
that the the top factor that we'll talk
about today
is whether the product is a contact or a
systemic some people will call
a contact a protectant so a contact
product is one that remains on the
surface like a chlorophyllenol or a
mangostep product
remains on the the surface of the leaf
um
contact products tend to be more because
they're on the surface of the plant they
tend to be more
susceptible to
rain and wash off than systemic products
which which move into the plant
so because i was not able to find a lot
on the labels
what i want to do now is go through and
talk about some
uh
studies that scientists have done
scientists like myself who have done pro
studies where they put a rain machine in
a greenhouse
and turn apply fungicides and turn on
the rain machine for various amounts and
various amounts of time
and and and see what happens to to
answer just the question which we've
been asking here
and so i'll go over that and i'll try to
make that
uh information as is digestible as
possible
i i wanted to mention that after i gave
this talk the last time
uh somebody turned me on to a
a youtube video with with uh
industry scientists talking about
fungicides and they were talking about
how
the vast majority of fungicides are are
are systemic and the only limit to how
fast
they put on the label was
at the time between when they the
fungicide was applied to these plants
and the time when they could get it in
the rain chamber
but if that's true i i have not found
that for the most part on the label so
we'll
go ahead and examine those products so
first we'll talk about contact
fungicides
the first product we'll talk about is a
chlorothalonil product acanel
weatherstick
they found this this group here
i found high loss from rain 60 minutes
or less after application
and they found that they concluded that
it was best to apply
this product eight to 24 hours before a
rain
and they were working with dollar spot
on creeping bent grass so we'll come
back to that time period because i think
for many mac because
for many contact products that 8 to 24
hour
interval sounds like it makes a lot of
sense
here's another chlorothalo product bravo
500 in this case we're playing it on
potato
they found rainfall on the day of
application
was produced the greatest loss of
residue which makes sense that that
falls into that 8 to 24 hour period that
we just mentioned
they found residue loss from the top of
the plant but even even if the it lost
residue from the top of the plant there
was some redistribution to the bottom
leaves
small amounts of rain were
were
removed from
uh some of the fungicide residue
uh
small amounts of rain removed some of
the fungicide residue but the remaining
was difficult to remove so uh the
initial rain removed some but the what
what was on the leaf uh tended to stay
on the leaf
uh here's uh some mancazo products
diethane and ventum
uh this group was using 24-hour residue
and .6 inches of rain and they reduced
macca sub residues by by forty percent
they were working with apple leaves
uh here's another mancas up product
dysen ultra
uh a fifth inch of rain is what they
used four hours after after application
they lost they found a 75 percent loss
of residue when they were working with
apple leaves as well
they recommended a drying time of at
least four hours
and they recommended using
whatever
adjuvants were on the label
and that's something that i think is
important whether for rainfast or for
other purposes if the label lists
an adjuvant i would use that unless you
have good reason not to
and this comment on diethane f45 said
that
addition of a registered surfactant
will improve initial spray deposits
fungicide redistribution and
weatherability which i would think
includes uh rain vastness
so here's um copper product the copper
products are also products that are
susceptible contact products they're on
the outside of the leaf in this case an
apple leaf and they are susceptible to
being washed off as well this group used
0.2 inches of rain three hours after
application and found that that point
two inches of rain washed off eighty
percent
of
the
copper
um here's our animex schindler's group
at michigan state university she was
working with 24-hour residue
one inch of rain she found removed 50
percent of the residue and two inches
from rain removed the remaining
and i think she was working with grapes
so let's move on to systemic fungicides
now these are fungicides which move into
the leaf and what we'll find is for the
most part systemic fungicides that move
into the leaf are less susceptible to
being washed off
so here's a group that's using the the
a product secure or omega
the active ingredient fluorasinam
they found it was effective even 15
minutes after rain so
fluazinam is interesting because it's a
contact fungicide
it doesn't move once it's in the leaf
but it does move into the leaf
and that in itself was enough to to make
it very
rain fast they're working with dollar
spot and creeping
bent grass and they recommended one hour
of of rain fastness one hour after one
hour it was rain fast
uh here's an oxy-strobin
heritage
effective even 15 minutes after a rain
they're working with brown patch and
fall fescue and so they also recommended
one hour of rain fast it was a rain fast
after an hour
this is an anime schindler's group again
at michigan state using uh a quadrus
product
one day old residue they found two
inches of rain did not reduce
effectiveness but that same rain reduced
the residue to sixty percent so
interestingly enough uh that there uh a
lot of rain reduced the the the residue
but it it didn't reduce the
effectiveness and she was working with
uh phamopsis and grapes so what what
factors then reduce
uh uh fungicide residue well any kind of
weathering that could be rain as we've
been talking about or wind
uh but
uv radiation sunlight
uh will reduce fungicide residue over
time and then of course growth if your
plants are growing uh then for the most
part those that growth is not going to
have fungicide residue on them
um so let's return to those questions
then rain fastness the first question
should i wait until it rains before i
apply a fungicide and i would say in
most cases
apply a fungicide before a rain
it's important to get that fungicide on
before it rains because
a rain event is when those that disease
gets spread around so
in most cases
apply the fungicide before a rain
if i apply a fungicide before rain how
long for its rain fast well i don't know
if there's any
uh sure answer on this unless it's it's
on the label and i urge you to look at
the label but for contact products a
good rule of thumb is 8 to 24 hours
before rain it becomes rain fastness and
i would say most systemic products seem
to be in in an hour or two
i applied a fungicide yesterday and it
rained today should i reapply
in most cases i would say not today
if
you applied a fungicide yesterday and it
rained today
i would not apply something else today
or tomorrow but you might increase the
frequency if it was uh really
uh severe rain uh maybe instead of
waiting seven days you wanna go
uh five days or maybe instead of waiting
ten days you wanna go seven days but i
would go back in and and
apply the fungicide again right away
older residues are more likely to need
reapplication so if you are on a 10-day
uh schedule and you get a really bad
rain
at eight days you might want to go ahead
and reapply
and then as we've mentioned contact
products are more likely to need
reapplication
than
systemic products
so let's go over then some rules for
fungicide
applications
apply most fungicides on a 7 to 14 day
schedule so we mentioned
weathering and growth and for those
reasons most fungicides will need
allocation during during the season um
you'll you'll have more frequent
applications in wet weather not not just
because we're washing off the residue
but because
uh
as we've seen wet weather
is is is linked closely to disease so
if it's raining a lot we we want more
fungicide applications and if it's in
august and it's really dry we can
probably spread those out to a two-week
schedule
in indiana we have a weather-based
disease forecasting system for cucurbits
in that case uh go ahead and use that
and that that takes the guesswork out of
the
wind to spray
but but as i say for most crops i would
use a 14 day minimum
apply protectants 8 to 24 hours for rain
if you can
apply the the protectant but or the
contact product before
a rain if you possibly can
but but probably eight to
after eight to four hours it it's
probably gonna be rain fast systemics uh
like i say i'm thinking one to two hours
before a rain
check your pre-harvest interval
um don't don't forget that when you're
scheduling fungicides and then check the
label for more information and like i
say i tried to check most of the labels
but but you won't of course want to
check
the label you're using for any
information about rain fastness
so when i give this talk
uh i've i'm often somebody will come up
to me afterwards or from the audience
and and tell me a story like this
um
um and this is this is a a
so one of the growers
that i work closely with uh tells this
story so he this grower has has an adult
son and this is several years ago
back when pretty much all we had to
spray was chlorothalonil
um and and he he sent his son out to
spray his watermelon field this thing
went on spray and we got one of these
southern indiana toad strangler rains
tractor got stuck and the dad had to go
and rescue the sun
out of the tractor and then a few days
later they had to go and pull the
tractor out and of course that made huge
ruts
well
what the grower noticed is
right up into the point where the sun
had been spraying fungicide there was
less disease after the point where the
tractor had gotten stuck
there was more disease so this doesn't
fall into that 8 to 24 hour period like
i mentioned
but still any if you can possibly get
that fungicide on before rain you should
probably just go ahead and put it on
um
because uh the rain is really when you
need that
that fungicide on the leaf because rain
is what
is closely linked to disease
and i have um one more story to tell you
that the
my mentor here and the man who had this
job before
dr rick latin here at purdue who's now
retired
when growers would ask him this question
should i wait until the rain to spray my
fungicides he would give a football
analogy
um he would say
if if waiting to put your fungicides on
after rain is like putting your football
helmet on after the game
when you need the helmet is during the
game when you need the fun side on is is
during the rain so
and with that uh here's my contact
information
um i'm be glad to answer questions
well we're typing perhaps dan i want to
say that was a really interesting talk
um one question i had is
did you come across any research on you
know infero atlantic fungicides and the
effect of big rain events right after
that
um obviously a different story than
foliar applications i'm just curious
no i i haven't done that um that and
that's a another good question
but i it's a it's a i guess it's a
different story because i think
rain and foliar diseases are linked so
so much
um
i i guess no i had the answer is no i
haven't done any research but i've often
thought that when i'm applying
fungicides on and i want the root to
take it up i'd rather do it when the
soil is dry
so that can take it up but i really
haven't done any research on that
here's a question from laura perkins
and her question is do freak warm wet
days
like today in ithaca and geneva open the
possibility of infection
so um
so i it's interesting i'm not quite sure
uh you know what you have out there on a
day like today strawberries or something
like that
um i would so when you think about when
you think of when i think about
infection windows i think about two
things
i think about uh warm
warm weather peach leaf curl
hmm
okay yeah i don't
uh
i guess i don't know a lot about peach
leaf curl but um yeah that that's an
interesting question
um well we're at 38 degrees so you guys
must be warmer than us
you have to uh
yeah i'm just i'm just really not sure i
think when i think about uh infection
windows i think about temperature but i
also think about uh time so you have to
have you know probably 12 hours or how
many hours at that temperature and if
you have that amount of time and and i
don't can't remember what peach leaf
curl is
then then yeah i think it's possible but
you have to have that leaf material out
there
do you have do you have you do have
peach leaves out now
i'm not sure
uh one one of the other qu one of the
other questions was should we mix
protect it in a systemic i i just think
that that's
pretty much always a good idea with and
i think uh somebody's gonna be talking
about uh frac codes mode of action codes
and i think that gets into the to that
but
um
it's probably not a bad idea to mix and
protect it with a systemic
maybe that next speaker will address
that
yeah i've got another question for you
on the chat from dan wicksted and it
reads with climate change more heavy
rain events are happening
what level of rain event are label
statements based on um one inch per hour
for example one inch per hour
oh that's yeah that's a good question uh
like i said i was it was it was i was
turned on to this video
and and
they were very optimistic about
the these industry people were in very
optimistic about the rain fastness
uh but they did not mention
uh
how you know whether it was an inch or
two inches or something like that i
guess i would say that if it's in the
leaf it's in the leaf if it's a systemic
product and it probably it doesn't
really matter
um it it it's more
uh maybe if you have a contact or
protectant product on the leaf that
that's when you're
it the total amount is going to vary and
of course the other thing which
wasn't asked but
with phytophthora with phytophthora
diseases
i i've noticed well everybody knows i
guess that that
when you have that puddling rain that's
that's really a factor
great thanks so much and good afternoon
everyone thanks for your attention today
as we go through some of the basics of
pesticide use
uh today i have one goal for you well
two goals i should say i have two goals
that i want you to get out of this talk
as we start rolling into our
you know april is coming close and soon
we'll be thinking about fungicides and
pesticides i want you to know what are
fractals and what why should we bother
with them why do we care um there are
these things that are on the label
um then you might just sort of your eyes
glaze over and you're like ah it's just
a bunch of numbers amongst a bunch of
other bunch of numbers um but they're
actually incredibly important and
they're important because more than 80
percent
of the crops grown in the united states
are treated with some form of fungicide
whether it be a
uh broad spectrum
and whether it be a single site a
biopesticide there are you know
a big concern right is crop loss due to
fungicides sorry due to fungi and
fungicides are our best tool that we
have to combat
these pathogens
as a quick refresher before i go into
the actual talk of what our frat codes i
want to just go over some terminology
fungicides when i'm describing those as
a compound that kills a fungal fungal
organism or their reproductive spores
a fungi static is a compound that's
going to inhibit the growth of a fungal
organism it's not going to kill it
outright
in general you can separate fungicides
into two um
[Music]
categories there's your conventionals
which are synthetic compounds engineered
for specificity efficacy safety and
reduced input
they're usually the ones with a big
price tag
and then you've got your biofungicides
and i'm going to say i might use the
word biopesticide interchangeably but
remember that biopesticide is an
umbrella term that also includes
insecticides herbicides you know a pest
of some sort but biofungicide is the
most accurate term to be using when
we're talking about a fungal specific
compound but biofungicides are naturally
occurring fungicidal substances and
these can be microorganisms living
organisms that are going to kill fungi
they could be the byproducts of
microorganisms or they could be plant
incorporated protectants that are going
to act on the plant such that its immune
system is boosted to fight off fungal
infection
now fungicides have many modes of action
and they in general they have two broad
categories they can have a multi-site
mode of action meaning that the compound
in question will inhibit a range of
enzymes or cellular structures in a
non-systemic way
it's just going to just be able to
camber the fungi from all fronts in
order to kill it or suppress it such
that you don't get disease development
or the compound might be a single site
fungicide meaning that it's going to act
at a specific point in a biosynthetic
pathway in the pathogen so it would for
example
work to
you know inhibit the ability of the
fungal spores to germinate or it's going
to inhibit the ability of the fungus to
produce energy such that it can keep
growing once it's already established on
a
plant surface
and when it comes to single sites that's
where the focus of this talk is going to
be because resistance is our biggest
concern and that is decreased
susceptibility of a pathogen population
in your orchard or in your field to a
specific fungicide and that's where
frack comes in
so frac or the fungicide resistance
action committee was founded as a
way to prevent and manage the use of
fungicides to prevent fungicide
resistance frac is a specialist
technical group of an organization
called crop life international which
represents the plant science industry
all around the world their members are
include major players in the crop
protection industry so think of you know
bayer
basf corteva they all have
representatives on this group as well as
um fungicidal scientists from all over
the world from the major universities
and the reason that they're so vested in
keeping you know using this frac system
in order to keep fungicides effective
for longer is that it's very expensive
to bring fungicides to market so here's
an example of a 2018 report
that gives you a sense of what it takes
to bring a fungicide to market um it's
going to take you around 11 years and a
little over 300 million dollars to
discover develop and register a new
fungicide and that doesn't even include
the cost of them marketing it and then
getting it out to production this is
just to invent the darn thing and get it
out the door
so
we need to make sure that these products
which are very expensive to produce and
very expensive to buy
are
available as long as possible so we
don't reduce the number of tools in our
tool kit to
manage the diseases that are most
concerning to us as growers
so a frac code
is going to be found on every fungicide
label
in the united states you're going to
find it displayed prominently usually on
the first page or right on the front if
you're looking at your bottle
so you'll find it usually in some form
like this you know group and then a code
itself like p5
group 21 or in this case you might find
some products that are actually a mix of
two different frac chemistries in this
case seven and 11 for this product
called marathon
and they're they're sort of a tool to
help you quickly generate your fungicide
application plan as you go into your
growing season
so when it comes to single site
fungicides fracs are registered for a
limited number of uses per season and
you should be rotating fungicides with
different frac groups throughout your
growing season and i'll get into why we
do that in a second remember we're just
answering the what right now so frac
recommends for example that you
shouldn't be using no fewer than three
different frac compounds
or in any given growing season or for
multi-spray crops like potatoes which
have a lot of input requirements you
should be using no fewer than five
different frat compounds
because you want to be using different
modes of action per crop slash disease
combination that you're most concerned
about in your particular crop
for effective resistance management
so my experience is largely with apples
that's from most of my research is
conducted so i want to give you that
information in the context of an apple
management disease plan
so what we have here is a fungicide
schedule for any generic growing season
on the left here you've got the growth
stage of apple through its different uh
phenological stages as you go from the
early spring in
oh late march early april depending on
the season as far as the mid-summer
around second cover we've got our target
pathogens apple scab and powdery mildew
that we're most concerned about is the
fungal diseases of concern for apple
management
and here are the commercial products and
the active ingredients that those
products contain and most importantly
are the fret codes so if you're laying
out your fungicide plan for the growing
season you can sort of look down and use
these tools to help you quickly see hey
am i rotating my fret codes enough am i
including enough of a variety to meet
the requirements that frack the
organization recommends such that i
don't have disease resist or fungicide
resistant
concerns so for example here for apples
you know i would recommend using
something like aprovia a frac seven
inspire super which is actually a mix of
three and nine
or flint extra 11 and i'm using them and
i'm alternating them rotating them such
that i don't use any one product
um too many times in a given season and
i don't go over the total number of four
applications of a particular fret code
in a growing season
so with the what a fractions answered
they're a tool in order for us to
effectively manage fungicide resistance
in the pathogen populations of concern
why why do we care about it and the
answer is fungicide resistance so let's
go back to that grower with that
schedule again and pretend that well
he's not interested in rotating his
fungicides instead they're much more
interested in just using the same old
product over and over and over because
one yeah it's expensive to have to buy
three or four different compounds right
you know there's an upfront cost
associated with buying you know six or
seven compounds
of different fret chemistries and also
you use what you know right you know
somebody tells you down the street or
you know that sunday at church hey i use
a provia it's great it does the job so
i'll just use that for everything so
here's a situation where growers just
decided to use some
multi-sites in their early season just
to deal with low disease pressure but as
the pressure really ramps up through the
rest of the growing season they start
using aprovia all season long and they
do this this year next year the year
after that and they do this for the next
five years and that's where we get
fungicide resistance to come from
so there's three phases of fungicide
resistance there's emergence which i've
just sort of shown to you in a that
table form
where the grower has used the same
product in this case aprovia of frack
group 7 over and over and over for many
years
now i do want to stress here that the
emergence of fungicide resistance in a
particular
fungal population is not due to the
fungicide itself fungicides are not
inherently metagenic they're not
creating mutations that lead to
resistance instead what a fungicide is
doing is it's selecting for pre-existing
mutations already found in the
population of the fungi that you're most
concerned about these fungi are getting
these mutations due to the shuffling of
their genetic material when they
reproduce uh so these and i will point
that these advantageous mutations occur
very infrequently so that's why we don't
have you know reports of fungicide
resistance every single day it takes
time in order for these mutations to one
develop and then to be selected for
now select selection is the second phase
of resistance development in a fungal
population so if this grower keeps using
say for example aprovia over and over
and over
it will select it will remove the
resensitive isolates from his in this
case orchard but it could be a field
and you'll be left with only your
resistant isolates this sub population
of that total fungal population that
you're concerned about
let's just say the grower doesn't notice
this and they just keep using the same
products over and over and over and
that's actually going to lead to
establishment because by removing all of
the sensitive isolates you've
effectively freed up all of this free
real estate for the resistant isolate to
take over all this green tissue that is
now theirs to conquer because there's
nothing else nothing for them to
you know to slow them down and the
current fungicides being used are
effective so at this point the grower is
wasting their money uh in short words um
because it's not going to do the job
that they're setting up to do by
applying fungicides in the first place
so this is the goal of using fracs to
make sure that this process emergence
selection and establishment doesn't
occur
so i want to go through sort of a q a of
sort of the common questions that i get
about um using the use of frac codes and
fungicide resistance in in general i
will say that my like i said i i work
largely in apple so that's sort of the
lens that i'm looking through things but
this does apply to sort of fungal
pathogens in general whether it be an
orchard or a field
so my first question that i often get is
how far will a resistant pathogen
population move
and i'll say here that it largely
depends on the pathogens dispersal
method this comes down to the biology of
the pathogen it has nothing to do with
whether or not it's resistant to a
fungicide or not
in general airborne pathogens are the
most concerning uh we've learned that
you know with a human pathogen
relatively recently
so if we look at this chart here a soil
board fungal pathogen is going to be
most concerning at the plant scale right
so think of like a soil-borne fungi like
pithium uh
it's just not going to be able to move
terribly far in the soil it's not sorry
it will be able to move somewhat in the
soil but it's not going to be able to
get to the field scale and move from one
end of your field to the other 100
meters away and it's certainly not going
to move from farm to farm without some
extra help a waterborne pathogen is
going to follow a similar style right
within a field especially on a like a
sopping wet field think of like
phytophthora for example
it's going to be able to affect plants
in a broad patch it might even be able
to move within the field reasonably well
as long as if there's you know a conduit
for that water to travel and pathogen to
move with it but from farm to farm again
that's going to be very low it's
airborne that's your biggest concern
because once those spores are released
it's really a matter of how far the wind
carries them and they are able to find
tissue to land on and set up shop again
that sort of limits its dispersal i will
make a point here that human activity is
going to modify dispersal dramatically
so for example a soil-borne pathogen
that you normally wouldn't care about
beyond the plant scale could be an issue
at the farm scale if for example you're
not sanitizing your tractor after a
particularly you know driving through a
field that has a historical prevalence
of soil-borne pathogens or with
waterborne pathogens say you've got
irrigation lines that you're not
cleaning out that have been infected and
then you're just moving that equipment
from site to site you're just taking the
pathogen with it so keep that in mind
um when it comes to resistance right
these are the
vectors by which a fungicide resistant
population might be able to move around
um another question i get is is it
better to rotate products of different
groups after one application or two
applications and the answer is is that
it doesn't really matter within season
how frequently you're rotating as long
as you're following those label
requirements of a max number of
applications in a given year which is
for the single sites largely four
because the time needed for fungicide
resistance to develop in a found gold
population is on a seasonal to
multi-year scale so with our apple
grower example that person was spraying
a frac seven for many many years in a
row that led to fungicide resistance
development in that population
um it's not just going to be a week to
week thing that leads to resistance it
doesn't typically happen that fast
although i reserve the right to you know
find a biology to surprise us in a way
and uh to beat us to it
now if you have a pathogen population
resistant to a specific frac group let's
say that frack seven in that example
earlier will that person be ever able to
use fungicides from that group
effectively again and if so how long do
they have to wait
um the answer unfortunately is unclear
and totally up to the pathogen of
concern it really depends sometimes a
pathogen may reverse so here's an
example of a resistant isolate
in your let's say a field or an orchard
and the grower stops using a particular
frac group that led to the resistance in
question
and they have to wait a long time and
that time indeterminate totally
dependent on the pathogen and the
resistance mutation that they have
whether or not the mutation is uh
removed over many generations or after
only after a few generations of that
fungal population it might regain
sensitivity and you'll be able to use
that frac group in the future or which
is the situation we don't want
the pathogen population maintains that
resistance permanently and then spreads
it elsewhere and it sort of becomes the
normal status of that particular fungal
path so this is the situation we're
certainly not interested and this is why
it's so important to rotate track groups
such that we don't have the situation
arise
um to give you a case study um to sort
of see how long could you have to wait
to see resistance sensitivity to a
particular frat group come back
uh in apple there's a disease called
apple scab caused by fungus called
ventria in equalis
and in the years leading up to 2000 in
new york and michigan orchards there was
a compound called dodea track group u12
that was incredibly effective against
this pathogen and it was used
very widely
however
resistance appeared and we had to take
it off the market but my advisor karen
cox who works on this system
did some work in the early 2000s to see
how long would it take for dodean to be
effective again so as we look at these
charts here
um this on the y-axis is the percentage
of orchards indicating um how many of
those isolates were able to grow in the
presence of
dodea so on the x-axis is doty here
and how many of the athletes can grow in
a lot of dodin versus are very sensitive
to donating and they die off very easily
so in 2004 right after they stopped
duties and building and the resistance
would have at its highest peak
um
many many isolates were able to grow in
the presence of this compound meaning
indicating that they were resistant and
then as 2007 2009 and then actually 10
years later 11 years later from 2000 the
path the amount of pathogen that could
successfully grow in dodean had reduced
meaning that it had become sensitive to
this
compound and you could start using
dodean again however because of the
uh liberal use of dodean back early
before 2000 it isn't even really used by
growers that much anymore
because of resistance you know
resistance coming back fuse so it's
better to have not gotten into the
situation in the first place
if we do get into this situation you
might be in for a very long wait before
you might be able to use that compound
again
now are there groups where resistance in
pathogens develops more quickly than
others and the answer is yes and this
sort of reiterates the need to rotate
your frac roots
the fret groups with the highest
resistance development which i will say
are also some of the most effective
fungicides uh include the qois that's
euphrat group 11.
the
dicarboxamides and the sdhis 2 and 7
respectively
and then the dmis and the aps three and
nine
other single sites such as the pps and
the kris 12 and 17 have low to medium
resistance but you know they're not as
popular because they aren't necessarily
as effective to say the qis and sda
currents especially when you've only got
so many limited dollars for fungicide
you know purchases and you want to buy
what works the first time
uh if you're curious about whether or
not the frack groups that you are using
in your fields and orchards have what
their
risk
profile is for resistance development i
encourage you to go to www.frack.info
and you're going to download the frac
code table and you'll see this is a
segment of it specifically for the dmi's
fact group three
and you go hunt down the fret code that
you're interested in three in this case
and if you look in the comments it'll
tell you what is the risk
in this case for the dmi is for free
it's medium risk
now if you have uh resistance or
decreased efficacy to a particular frat
group in your orchard or in your field
against a particular fungal pathogen
that you're concerned about is it okay
to continue using it to manage the other
fungal pathogens in your field and
orchard and i'm going to tell you right
now ideally no ideally you stop using
that particular frac group altogether
and you set it aside such that uh
sensitivity to that frac group in the
pathogen that is now not you know it's
not working on as well sort of comes
back but we know no as we see earlier it
takes some time sometimes to do that so
your management program is probably
focusing on your most troublesome
diseases not just one disease
and it's inevitable that you're going to
keep on using a certain fracture but you
know why should you try not to do that
and this is due to two things something
called multiple resistance or cross
resistance in a scenario where multiple
resistance is formed a fungal pathogen
is going to develop resistance to two
unrelated fungicide classes so going
back to that grower who used frack group
seven and use just approvia all season
long
um they you know that's already been
lost to them track group sevens they're
resistant to but then they come along
and because they weren't able to rotate
effectively now they're starting to see
resistance to a completely different
track group say rap group 3 for example
and once again they're wasting their
money and they've got a big problem on
their hands when it comes to protecting
their crop
in cross resistance it's a situation
where the pathogen is going to
show resistance to multiple fungicides
within the same mode of action so
aprovia frack group seven um sorry
excuse me frat group seven which
includes a compound black aprovia
there's also other products within that
label that now might not be as effective
as well because they're hitting a
similar
target within the fungal pathogen so
that means you're going to lose an
entire frac group not just one specific
product within that frac group and
that's that's you know a huge concern as
you only have so many frac groups to
work with to manage your diseases
one of the biggest questions i get is
are higher or lower rates better for
resistance management you come in
swinging with the highest rate possible
and just try to burn out the fungi
that's causing a problem or do you just
sort of like
apply a low dose but maybe maybe more
frequently or just try to find a way to
sort of burn it out slowly um this is
going to be different for
you know i i encourage you to talk with
your extension arm of wherever you're
growing because i can't speak to a lot
of different pathogens other than those
in apple but our data suggests that for
apple scab you're going to want to apply
um
[Music]
a high rate right away every single time
low doses applied year after year may be
promoting resistance because it's just
sort of like introducing it's like drip
feeding the fungus with that fungicide
too slowly such that it's able to select
for resistance
so we recommend the use of high dose
rates and frac group rotation
along with a liberal use of multi-site
fungicides and bio-pesticides in
rotation um i will say that human and
veterinary medicine has taken the same
approach right like if a doctor
prescribed you
an antibiotic or an anti-fungal you
wouldn't take half of your dose or stop
halfway through your treatment program
right you know you need to take the
entire course of the medicine to burn
out whatever is causing the problem in
you or in your orchard uh respectfully
so where do biofungicides fit into this
frat code picture well they're cataloged
too uh the code bm or biologicals with
multiple modes of action is used for uh
bio-pesticides um the great thing about
bio-pesticides is that there isn't any
resistance they don't have they have a
very low risk of resistance development
in the fungal pathogens that they
control
so there's definitely value with using
these products
in rotation with single sites and in
rotation with multi-site fungicides
to manage your diseases of concern
if you want to learn more about frat
codes i encourage you to go to
www.frac.info
uh there you're going to find the
fungicide resistance management
recommendations by crops since i can't
speak general you know knowledgeably
about anything more than just apple uh
it will also give you a list of the
pathogens most at risk for fungicide
resistance development i'll give you a
hint detritus grey molds is one of the
worst ones it just it can snap up
fungicide resistance real quick so if
you're dealing with uh gray molds for
example in strawberry production or
small fruit production that's a huge
concern
also and most i'd say importantly you're
going to find the frac pathogen risk
uh code list right here and this is this
master list of frac codes which is going
to break down all of the available
fungicides by their fret code and by
their mode of action so you can make
sure that you're rotating most
effectively
so what have we learned
codes are developed to facilitate
fungicide resistance management in crops
worldwide their goal is to prolong the
effectiveness of the limited tools that
we have to manage fungal diseases
it's very important that you know the
group code for the fungicides that
you're using to avoid rotating among
chemically similar fungicides it might
be easy to use the same product over and
over and over but you're going to be
better served in the long run by buying
a handful of products with different
frat codes and making sure that you're
using them in rotation all season long
once you've established fungicide
resistant populations in your field or
orchard it's not guaranteed that they're
ever going to go back to being a
sensitive version of themselves
and you're going to have lost a very
limited expensive tool um not only for
yourself but for those who come after
you to grow in those locations
um i'd be more than happy to take any
questions that you have about fungicide
resistance and if you have some apple
questions i guess i can take a shot at
those as well thanks very much for your
attention
i have a just a question on that frac
info david um
how often does the uh that frack group
typically update their um you know their
pdf and their info i know in the last
couple years we've seen some changes um
in terms of which of groupings and how
how some newer products and newer
biologicals are grouped um is that
typical or you know do you any
predictions on where that's going to go
yeah so the frac group is very active
and they update that pdf every single
year um so you can get the most current
one
hopefully it's live by now um for 2020
actually it is because i took that
screenshot just the other week when i
built the talk so yeah there's the 2021
is available now whether or not all the
different companies get their labels
updated you know if the threat groups
change that's that's on them i'm
assuming there's a lot of legal
repercussions that they don't so that
should be current as well
i see a question from laura perkins do
fungi build up resistance to copper or
sulfur um short answer no
um and that's that's a great thing right
so copper and sulfur the you know the
inorganics fungicides um they're broad
spectrum so it's just the merely the
contact of these compounds that are
going to kill
fungi fungal
the fungi itself or the fungal spores
that it produces um it's going to be
able to burn those out so our
concerns of resistance development is is
next to nothing so you can use those
products um effectively um but there's
also other concerns for using just
sulfur or just copper
for example you know the environmental
effects right of dumping these it
usually takes a lot more of these
compounds to
manage diseases as well as the residue
that you find in your crop so that's why
we try to rotate those with single sites
and biopesticides
tony you asked do protectants mixed with
systemic fungicides and rotations help
with chances of resistance uh insurance
are yes they do um and yeah and so for
example with that um table i had of the
apple grower who rotated between some
multi sites and some single sites that
was the goal there right so
let's say you've got a situation where
the grower is only going to be using
one single site we know that's a bad
idea i hope i've established that in
this talk but let's say that they are
going to use aprovia all season long for
the next five years
that is much worse than using aprovia
all season long but alternating it with
a mult over the multi-site
both of those are bad ids this is just
for the sake of example um but what's
happening in the situation where the
grower is
using
aprovia and then sulfur and then
appropriate and then sulfur instead of
just aprovia aprovia aprovia crack 7 7
and x7
is that it's giving that window if
assuming that there's a 10 to 14 day
window between applications that sulfur
window means that there's now going to
be you know
20 some odd days between an appropriate
application and an approviat application
meaning that you're not going you're
going to kill off
hopefully resistant isolates with your
your broad spectrum sulfur application
your protectants and you're not going to
keep selecting for resistance by wiping
out just sensitive isolates and allowing
the resistant isolate to take over all
of that free real estate so
that was for the sake of example
obviously make sure you are you know
rotate your protectants and multi sites
or sorry single sites but make sure also
you're rotating your single sites within
your single site applications to make
sure that you get the best possible
result um but that is why the use of
protectants is so effective to manage
resistance development among single site
fungicides
great question
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu